all right we've got el salvador now back
in june
nick carter who is a fan of the show who
is a partner of the show who is
basically like an extended uh honorary
pump brother at this point who will be
coming back to the show on a periodic
basis was holding a twitter spaces uh
and
i joined a couple other people joined we
started talking about what's going on in
el salvador they were putting forth the
bitcoin bill uh then all of a sudden one
of president bukelli's brothers he
jumped in then a second brother jumped
in then all of a sudden president
buchelli himself out of nowhere off the
top rope 360 dunk he jumped in jack
dorsey mark cuban it was like the whole
internet was in this twitter space
there's over 20 000 people in there and
we started to ask the president a bunch
of different questions some of the
questions were real simple why are you
doing this how does the legislation work
what's the opposition think etc but then
out of nowhere alex gladstein asked the
president have you thought about using
state resources to mine bitcoin or
participate in the mining process and
president buchelli what seemed like kind
of an offhand comment at the time said
oh actually we have a ton of energy from
volcanoes we have volcano energy and
we've actually been thinking about
potentially mining bitcoin using that
volcano energy now you can imagine being
in one of these twitter spaces late at
night on the east coast 20 000 people
all listening to hear the president of a
nation say that he's going to use
volcano energy to start mining bitcoin
people went nuts now what ended up
happening was there was a lot of
questions are they actually gonna mine
bitcoin with volcano energy or is this
just a politician making uh campaign
promises and and trying to say the
things that he thinks people are going
to be excited about well we now have the
story el salvador has started to mine
bitcoin using energy from volcanoes so
they've actually built it we talked
earlier this week we got a little teaser
video they came out and they said hey
it's getting close now we have true
confirmation so el salvador i was
looking it up this morning the best
business show research team it's known
as the land of volcanoes what does that
mean i don't know but that's what the
internet says they got a lot of
volcanoes and they look pretty dope i
don't know who took this picture but
it's awesome and so when you start to
think about a volcano i think most
people like think of the concept but
they forget no they erupt there's lava
that comes at them these are real things
and there's just the uh geothermal
energy that's inside of them and so in
this land of the volcanoes the president
of el salvador uh posted about six hours
ago seven hours ago an account balance
he literally just posted this is as
transparent as you possibly can get and
what you can see here is that they have
started to mine satoshi's that's right
the country of el salvador has bought
mining equipment for bitcoin they have
plugged it into the geothermal power
that comes from the volcano energy
within the volcanoes in their country
and they now are mining bitcoin he then
followed it up with another tweet that
said we're still testing and installing
but this is officially the first bitcoin
mining from the
the volcanoed
[Laughter]
which is a great
great marketing term here and also i
would like to say that you have to
respect uh bu kelly's use hashtags uh
emojis like the guy understands the
internet right
he tweeted literally just like the like
happy face with like hearts around it
when he showed the set the sound go back
to the uh the first tweet that he had
and also i mean you gotta respect that
uh what we showed yesterday i think the
chivo wallet dashboard he's just like
hey look here's the stats also here's
the account balance like imagine if the
uh us president was just out here
tweeting the fed balance sheet uh and oh
wait wait hold on let us uh edit it real
quick oh we just had another trillion
dollars all right but and when you see
this
the first thought i had this morning was
damn the country of el salvador is
moving faster and is becoming more
effective than most technology startups
like if i as a technology investor in
early stage startups saw a founder that
was doing this i would want to invest
right because i would say wow they set a
plan they executed quickly they're
communicating in a transparent way and
they're building an entire following
around this and then they're basically
doing the building in public and then on
top of that they're getting results
to go from we didn't even think of el
salvador as a country to do with
anything let alone with bitcoin to today
look at them as a leader on a global
stage in this specific fast-growing
industry and to have them already have
bought bitcoin already have over two
million of their uh uh citizens on board
it to an app that they built using atms
that they installed in the last 90 days
and on top of that now they're mining
bitcoin this has got to be one of the
most incredible things we've seen a
nation state do in a while yeah i mean
it's all happened very very very fast it
seems right i think i'm more curious too
like at what level do you think this is
for uh
kind of good purposes or at what level
do you think he's doing this because
he's getting kind of uh the publicity
and el salvador is receiving probably
attention on a global scale that they
haven't before right i think like
obviously that first mover advantage is
helpful from an innovation standpoint
but it also comes with we've talked
about this before like kind of the
publicity or the idea that you're
innovative or the idea that you are kind
of the first country of the people to be
doing this i assume part of that is is
it plays a role in his decision to be so
public about it and facing on twitter
and telling people exactly what he's
doing of course if every time you tweet
and you say we're doing this and people
go nuts what do you do
it's just dopamine hit so you do it
again right and what do you tweet again
people go nuts you tweet again and so at
some point you actually almost have the
marketing take over because you're
running out of things to brag about so
you have to get things done in order to
brag about it he wouldn't be able to
still be tweeting but like oh we passed
the legislation like people like dude we
got it like you you did that months ago
right then all of a sudden the wallet
we're gonna launch the wallet that got a
whole new cycle and then you got at some
point people were like all right dude we
know you're going to build the wall
where is it oh we launched it a whole
new news cycle then it's like okay now
you got the wallet well is anyone using
it news cycle is anyone using atms news
cycle hey remember that thing you said
about volcano energy what's going on
there oh we did it bam news cycle so
what they're doing is they're just
constantly executing and again you can
like them not like them whatever i'm not
an expert on salvadoran politics i don't
want to be but i think as you see that
execution you start to say hey things in
motion stay in motion and they have a
track record now of executing very
quickly very efficiently and when that
occurs in a fast growing industry like
this i wouldn't bet against them i would
not bet against this team
that is happens to be running a country
but could might as well just be running
a technology company because this is
what you would want to see out of a tech
entrepreneur as they are executing at
this speed they have over 20 volcanoes
in el salvador landed the volcanoes like
i said
john what do you think in a world where
governments are historically
slow to adapt and innovate especially in
new technology it's very impressive what
he's done it makes me a little worrisome
that he's almost moving too quickly um
but because there are there are risks
associated with everything right with
adopting a new technology like this on
such a wide scale but it is very
impressive that he's been able to do it
in such a quick manner and uh
effectively as well we got politicians
here complaining about the uh the energy
use of bitcoin uh talking about other
countries and how they want to shut it
down and how it's dangerous and all this
stuff and this guy in the span of of two
three months went out there not only is
adapting it where a large percent 30 or
40 percent of his entire country now
owns bitcoin but also they're mining it
from volcanoes it's it's it's uh super
impressive uh he obviously has some kind
of distinct advantage when it comes to
the relative small size of his country
and his ability to make decisions
personally but ultimately uh it's just
two drastic kind of things that we've
seen not only from the united states but
you look at someone like china who's
actively going out and banning it and
stopping people from adopting this
technology and then you look at him and
he is not only uh encouraging people to
use it but he's putting a an aggressive
plan into action uh not only to give his
citizens bitcoin but to mine it himself
the piece that nobody seems to give them
credit for is that they've done this
also with the pressure of the imf and
other countries being like hey i don't
know if we like what you're doing here
what's your plan et cetera and they're
not getting support oh he was chirping
at him
yeah i mean yeah
they're not getting
doing this this is absolutely a small
group of people who said we're gonna go
change the role and again maybe it has
positive impact maybe it has negative
impact you can debate all of that but
you cannot deny that there is a small
group of people in this country that
said we believe that there is a better
future and we're going to go after it
and whether they are successful or not
is still up for uh kind of debate and
we'll have great hindsight bias when we
look at the results but the early signs
of this are incredible he's already got
a piece of software in the market that
has more active users than any other
bank in all of el salvador
when you think about that like it's
crazy two million users i think the
country only has six or seven million
citizens so he's already got about a
third of his country on board in a
matter of weeks to a new piece of
software and they in 70 of his country
doesn't even have a bank account and so
when you start to see where this is
going
i can't believe that there's not gonna
be another country that says wow it
seems like bitcoin's good for business
you know what we should do uh we should
create legislation to make it legal
tender you know what else we should do
we should create a piece of software and
on board our country maybe we should
also create an atm network
you know we've probably got some energy
sources around here too maybe we should
go by uh mine bitcoin as well
and if they see the playbook work it's
almost like a bitcoin nation state
playbook is being created right in front
of our eyes similar to how michael
saylor at microstrategy created a
corporate balance sheet bitcoin playbook
and then he open-sourced and said hey
anyone who wants to do this go do it and
then we saw square we saw uh tesla
spacex etc all start to do this we saw
the bitcoin miners uh that are publicly
traded doing it as well i can't imagine
that other nation states aren't sitting
there saying like yep that is the way
let's go do it like yeah and if you look
at the adoption curve it starts to
accelerate right when you have not only
sure michael saylor was looked like
he was looked like an idiot or wild when
he first started doing this now there's
a bunch of kind of influential ceos and
companies that are putting on their
balance sheet and owning bitcoin
personally el salvador might be the
first country but you can quickly see
how other countries look at the playbook
like you said and then go out and adopt
it very quickly so anytime you have uh
kind of someone they get rewarded for
being that first mover but then it
starts to accelerate very quickly right
so el salvador may be the first i think
there's going to be a bunch of other
countries that probably end up doing it
eventually the real question just
becomes like how soon does it how soon
does it happen right is it three months
six months 12 months and then when you
look at it overlaid with the price if
the price starts to appreciate really
rapidly you can quickly see how these
people are forced to make decisions much
quicker than they would be so i wouldn't
be surprised if you look uh you know
this time next year and other countries
have adopted it or other countries are
actively looking to not only mine
bitcoin but give it to their citizens or
own a large percentage on their balance
sheets personally you would have to
believe that other countries are
analyzing and reviewing what is
happening in el salvador and then going
to take that and make their own
decisions based off that
the part that uh also feels um important
here is the everyday citizens
are not just going to transact with each
other so if you're if you're a
salvadorian who lives in el salvador
you're definitely going to go to
merchants you're going to send money
back and forth to other citizens live in
the country you also are sending money
back and forth with folks who live
outside of the country sometimes it's
your family your friends et cetera
remits is a very big part of the
salvadorian gdp
but those individuals start to onboard
then they get money in their accounts
and then they start to do it money is
the most viral product in the world and
so when you start to spin that viral
machine what happens is it just
infiltrates remember what i used to say
the virus is spreading you somehow in
2020 and 2021 weren't allowed to say it
i'm bringing it back the virus is
spreading it literally spreads like this
one mind virus this idea that once i
learned about bitcoin i can't stop
thinking about i tell joe about it joe's
like wow i got orange build as well now
he can't stop thinking about it he tells
john and it just spreads across a entire
population but also the virality of the
money itself if i want to go ahead and
send money to joe i say to him hey man
you got to be able to use an interface
that's plugged into the lightning
network whether you're using the chivo
wallet or using something else and it
constantly just pulls and pulls and
pulls more and more users onto the
network when you do that that is where
you end up getting the true viral
exponential kind of escape velocity
growth that we're seeing in the bitcoin
network what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you